you don't pay a lot attention to reviews
and those kind of things
well you know you're always affected by
opinion but the more opinions there are
of you the me the more I the less I look
at them because I just can't live my
life based upon what other people think
about me so I can't concern myself too
much with what other people think you
know it's just not healthy I don't think
I'll can I could continue to do what I
do if I was constantly worrying about
what somebody thought about it you don't
have to compromise yourself you know
it's something you don't feel good about
that don't do it the most important
choices I made was to say no and I said
you know many a time to film especially
girly on that just didn't feel
comfortable with they they there was one
script that was brought to me I call
that the [ __ ] they couldn't kill
like he was accused of raping his wife
in the forties and they would they try
to hang him but he didn't die they're
like it's a company I get it
so I actually called who I was fortunate
at that time to instill to be able to
call and I said you know this movie make
it I'm sick and they offered me six
hundred thousand dollars he said to me
the first three or four or five things
you made will determine how you're
proceeding I turned it down I turn money
back I needed the money I turned it down
six months later I got try freedom if
you don't feel like you should do it
then don't do it I think the most
important decision is saying that you
just watched two amazing clips from
Denzel Washington take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]